Yes, this one is low
The flowers from the embankment have come It
's the vibration wave drama on the right side
Even though it started, it was around that time that I mainly held two
cultural festivals, the school festival, the school festival, and the pet spring
clothing land attack.  When I was a
child,
I saw an animation called
Gengaku that will remain in history.
Mochi is also popular in the
United States, but I think it's popular in the United States, but I've
been saying this recently
Mari
This game isn't that new, so
I've seen it
too.  I
haven't seen the animation, but
I think it's behind
God Research Institute
.
Once today, the fact that our music is being accepted like I am is something that I
didn't feel at all this season at Kaidan Night.
I had a little bit of hope that I would tear it off,
but the dog
says it's more exciting than I thought
.
Musically, he
was influenced by American leaves and
longing, so
he was recognized for that broken penny
, just like him.
I'm so moved I regret this opportunity I'm glad
mebig Izumo is all about Japan
I think anime has penetrated America like this but
it didn't
In terms of
the quality of workmanship, it's a very well-made kosode
, and I'm sick of it, isn't it?
If you see it,
you'll be surprised.Last
month, Tomoko's bones
came to Chiba.Why are there so many Americans who are so enthusiastic about Japanese anime?
Or maybe it's because of the manufacturer, but since I cut
it, there's a lot of things like Uril neet, female Tom and Jerry
.
I wonder if it's a relationship or maybe they're sensitive people,
but after all, that's how
it spreads all over the world.
That's
right, I
was surprised that fugitive Zakima was the most,
yeah
2.
I was
told that I've already tried panning everything, but
there are things that I'm looking at too.
I
don't have a charm,
so it's a
strange feeling, isn't it? I
don't know, what would you think if my song actually
played in an animation
?
I feel like I'm watching it with that kind of feeling, so
I
'll leave it at that.When
we think about the songs
ourselves, it's a
strange feeling that they're
already being played in circles.
Animation and language will
also become necessary, but when such an
opportunity arises
,
I would like to continue my activities, so please continue to
support me
dare.